shark attacks midair collisions and
plummeting to their death unfortunately
these stunt actors lost their lives
making these movie scenes a reality
Harry O Conor who served as a stunt
double for Vin Diesel and trip XX died
on the prag set of the film while
performing a paragliding stunt in his
place an experienced skydiver and stunt
performer who joined the industry after
retiring as a Navy SEAL OK Conor
reportedly collided with the pillar of
the patski bridge while paragliding and
broke his neck in the process before
passing away it was his second effort to
complete the stunt the first of which
was successful and used in the movie
director Rob Cohen later said on his
commentary track we had 500 stuntmen
involved with this picture 499 didn't
get a scratch it shows you the length to
which we will go to bring this kind of
intense experience to the viewer
stuntmen know they are in danger they
make their living through danger most of
the time it's all right sometimes
unfortunately it isn't ok Conor was
44 you are America's best make us proud
stunt pilot art sh had become intern
nationally renowned for his aerial stunt
work in films like Blue Thunder and the
right stuff before he was selected to
complete an inverted air stunt that
would become a big part of the storyline
in Top Gun according to the Los Angeles
Times scha Was Heard relaying his inair
troubles during production on the scene
saying on his radio I've got a problem
here SCH was highly skilled at the
maneuver so colleagues concluded that
there must have been a mechanical
failure that caused his vessel to crash
however neither he nor his plane were
recovered from the debris despite a
search effort so the details leading up
to his death are unknown the mystery
that surrounds the failure that cost him
his life still lingers with his widow
Judy scha who told the Daily Mail art
didn't say what the problem was this is
the one thing I'm not happy about with
him so I don't know if he had a control
failure where maybe the camera jammed
into the flight controls or whether he
had an issue with the flight controls
where he wasn't able to get the airplane
out of the flat spin or whether he was
disoriented he didn't say scha was 53 in
one of the grizli accidents to ever
occur on a Hollywood set stuntman Jose
Marco a double for Bert Reynolds was
brutally attacked by a real life shark
while shooting an underwater scene for
shark Marco was filming alongside a
subdued bull shark in scuba gear when a
great white managed to make it through
the Nets protecting the area from the
rest of the sea and charged at the
camera crew before launching at Marco
and disemboweling the actor where he
swam crew members tried to steer the
shark away from Marco with Spears but
the animal was undeterred and the
stuntman's resulting injuries were so
severe that he died shortly after being
transported to the hospital the incident
was catastrophic but producers wanted to
and ultimately did use the Jam Marco's
death in the movie along with
publicizing the incident as a marketing
push director Samuel Fuller was so
disgusted that he disavowed the movie
unsuccessfully attempting to have his
name removed from its credits Marco was
32 the Vancouver candidate said of
Deadpool 2 became the site of a tragedy
in August 2017 when a stuntwoman named
Joy SJ Harris was killed while
attempting to complete a motorcycle
sequence for the film Harris was
substituting for actress zazi beats as
the character Domino and was not wearing
a helmet during the scene in question to
match the character Harris had
successfully completed the stunt four
times in a row but on the fifth attempt
she lost control of the vehicle and went
Airborne before careening into a glass
building local news crews reported that
she was treated on site by paramedics
after the incident but was later taken
to the hospital and ultimately declared
dead in a statement a rep for 20th
Century Fox Said of the incident we are
deeply saddened by the accident that
occurred on the set of Deadpool 2 this
morning our hearts and prayers are with
the family friends and colleagues of our
crew member during this difficult time
lead actor Ryan Reynolds echoed that
sentiment writing on X formerly known as
Twitter were heartbroken shocked and
devastated but recognized nothing can
come close to the grief and inexplicable
pain her family and loved ones must feel
at this moment my heart pours out to
them along with each and every person
she touched in this world Angela
bassett's double in Vampire in Brooklyn
had invited her mother and siblings to
the set of the film to watch her work on
the day her life was cut short Sonia
Davis's mother Wanda sap would later
reveal that she overheard her daughter
casting doubt on the safety of the stunt
she was about to perform during their
fateful visit telling the Los Angeles
son s the last words I heard my baby say
was when she yelled down to the stunt
coordinator are you sure I could feel
Sonia wasn't comfortable with the stunt
Davis had been performing a 42t backward
jump off of a building but rather than
Landing safely on the airbag That was
supposed to cushion her fall she instead
bounced back into the building before
making impact with the ground much to
her family's horror her mother initiated
a multi-million dollar wrongful death
suit against the studio Paramount
Pictures along with director Wes Craven
and producer star Eddie Murphy but the
case was ultimately dismissed stun
coordinators on the film would later
claim in an oral history of the movie
that Davis didn't perform the jump
correctly but there were also no
ambulances on set during the incident
Davis was
32 one
more Rest In Pieces The Expendables
movies were envisioned as a vehicle for
Pure action-driven spectacle bringing
together the biggest stars in the genre
led by Sylvester Stallone the films have
featured such heavyweight action heroes
as Arnold Schwarzenegger Bruce Willis
Chuck Norris Jet Lee Wesley Snipes and
many more but with all that action Comes
The increased risk of disaster and
tragically that's just what happened on
the set of The Expendables too during
production of a second unit water scene
on Lake annaya Nova Bulgaria stun actor
kunlu was killed and fellow double Neo's
son was severely injured when a planed
explosion went toye the pair were riding
on an inflatable rubber raft at the time
Lou was reportedly doubling for stone
himself while sun was subbing for Jet
Lee in the second unit shot Lou was just
26th at the time of his death and the
film was dedicated to his memory Sun
managed to survive his serious injuries
and filed suit against Sylvester
Stallone and Millennium films for
damages the family of Lou meanwhile also
pursued wrongful death damages against
the parties responsible for the movie
including stun coordinator Chad saheli
who went on to direct the John Wick Fels
in 2017 it was reported that the
plaintiffs were awarded
$195,000 Hong Kong dollars while jetley
himself gave 5.8 million Hong Kong
dollars to the stunt Man's family
written and directed by the late schlock
O2 Albert peun the 1982 sword and sandal
Adventure The Sword and the Sorcerer
starred Lee horley as Prince Talon who
learns he's descended from Noble blood
and must take on a powerful and evil
wizard though it's not one of that
decade's most memorable movies in the
genre it made the news after one of the
film's performers 37-year-old John hail
Jack Tyrie died in a stunt gone wrong
during production Tyrie was a veteran of
the industry who'd worked on everything
from Escape from New York to history of
the World Part One he was filming a
scene in Hollywood's Griffith Park for
The Sword and the Sorcerer in which he
was to jump from an 8 foot cliff he
unfortunately landed a few feet away
from the airbag intended to cushion his
fall causing severe injuries that
eventually cost him his life as reported
by the Calgary Herald an official said
at the time it was definitely a
high-risk stunt but Jack was a real
professional he had some more difficult
High Falls before tougher than the one
he faced on The Sword and the Sorcerer
perhaps surprisingly the stunt itself
was left in the film despite tyr's
tragic passing and the film was
dedicated to him in the credits the
James Bond franchise has built a
reputation for its impressive St stunts
and elaborate action sequences each film
in the series seems to attempt to top
the one before it and to do that can
sometimes mean making the stunts riskier
and riskier but by the time the
franchise got to its 12th entry in 1981
For Your Eyes Only the risk-taking may
have gone a little too far to create one
skiing and Bob sledding chase that takes
place amidst the wintry slopes of Italy
the film involved the use of a four-man
bob sled operated by a second unit
director to better capture footage of
the action unfortunately 23-year-old
Italian Sun driver Pao Roni fell off the
sleigh and was quickly killed after it
overturned and dragged him underneath it
wasn't the first or last Serious injury
to happen on the set of a James Bond
film but it was the deadliest it's been
reported that it was his death along
with the death of professional Bob
sletter James Morgan just a week earlier
during the 1981 bobsled World
Championships that prompted the decision
to shorten the Cortina Bob sliding track
where Roni was killed to make it safer
filmmaker John Woo was one of the
hottest action directors of the 9s after
a string of groundbreaking features in
his native Hong Kong woo was wooed by
Hollywood and came over to helm such
favorites as hard target Broken Arrow
and Faceoff by the late 2000s he was
back directing smash hits in China and
one of his first in his return to his
homeland was redcliffe starring Tony Le
young it was the highest grossing movie
of the year in the Middle Kingdom but
came at the cost of a stunt man's life a
period piece about the Battle of China's
Three Kingdoms the set of the film
became a deadly Inferno when a blaze
overtook the production claiming the
life of stuntman Lu yanqing and injuring
six other crew members the accident took
place during a ship battle scene in xao
Tang Shan just outside of Beijing during
the filming of the sequence a smaller
vessel engulfed in flames was planned to
collide with a larger ship but high
winds carried the fire to the second
ship and the flame spread uncontrollably
injuring those on board and killing
yanqing a statement from the US Studio
lionrock which was co-financing the film
read the crew of redcliffe is deeply
distraught and full of regret comes a
Horseman was a 1978 Western starring
Jane Fonda James Khan and Jason robarts
robarts start as Jacob JW ying a Rancher
who wants to protect his sprawling
Valley from big business tycoons who
would try to exploit it for its natural
resources working as robard stunt double
was stunt actor Jim Shepard who had a
wealth of experience on westerns like
the Wild Bunch and hour of the gun and
even sci-fi outings like Planet of the
Apes in comes a Horsemen Shephard was
filming a scene in which he was supposed
to be dragged behind a galloping horse
through a fence to simulate the death
and disappearance of robot's character
however the horse didn't stick to the
straight path through a gatas plant and
the unexpected ecoin Maneuvers caused
Shephard to be thrown off with his head
striking a fence post while he survived
the initial blunt head trauma he died
not longer after being hospitalized the
incident sadly occurred on one of the
last days of filming although the scene
did cut away from the Fatal Collision
the 41-year-old shepherd's last stunt
was still included in the picture hi
guys Colonel
McCoy I was just in the neighborhood
though mostly known for his martial arts
movies Chuck Norris made plenty of
military action flicks in the 80s with
Delta Force being one of his most
memorable a surprise called hit that
co-starred Lee Marvin and got a sequel
in 1990 Delta Force 2 the Colombian
connection for the followup it was
Norris headlining the action alone as
major Scott McCoy but like many other
action films Delta Force 2 also saw a
deadly helicopter crash during filming
that took the life of a stunt actor this
time it was in the Philippines where the
action sequel was shooting and it sadly
wasn't just stuntman Jeff Brewer who
lost his life in the crash alongside him
were pilots Don Marshall and JoJo
imperiale cameraman Gotti danzik and key
grip Mike Graham though only three men
died at the scene at least two more
succumbed to their injuries of the
nearly a dozen people hospitalized after
the accident to make matters worse the
production company notorious lowbudget
Studio Canon films had seen the deaths
of at least 10 people while filming
numerous projects over the course of 4
years another film in a long line that
saw deadly helicopter crashes during
production hired to kill is like Delta
Force 2 a lowbudget action movie from
1990 this one starring Brian Thompson
George Kennedy and Oliver Reed Thompson
plays a mercenary Who postes as a
photographer when he's hired to rescue a
freedom fighter being held Behind Enemy
Lines during filming the year before the
movie hit theaters a helicopter being
used to shoot a midair scene crashed
injuring the pilot and several others
and killing a stunt actor the actor
Clint Carpenter had been a regular stunt
man on the kids action series VR
Troopers and was riding with a pair of
fellow stuntmen while performing what
was later described as a routine flyby
moving across the camera's field
division set up on a rooftop the vehicle
attempted to make a tight turn for
unexplained reasons the helicopter
failed to achieve the turn and crashed
into a group of of trees killing
Carpenter who was pronounced dead before
he even made it to a nearby hospital
passengers Michael Kane pilot Mark wolf
and stunt coordinator Mark cutton along
with a third unknown stuntman all
sustained injuries though they suffered
broken ribs a leg fracture and a
punctured lung among them they were able
to escape with their lives Houston we
have a problem before Apollo 13 in 1995
it was 1983 is the right stuff that held
the title for best film about NASA's
spaceflight program oddly enough that
movie also included Apollo 13 Actor Ed
Harris who plays Astronaut John Glenn he
recounts the years that led up to the
launching of the Mercury 7 beginning
when Chuck jerger first broke the sound
barrier and includes all the incredibly
dangerous exploits of test pilots like
joerger Glenn and Alan Shepard the film
features several incredible high-flying
stunts and one of them involves a pilot
parachuting to safety from the confines
of an experimental aircraft unlike in
the movie though the pilot never did
make it home safely performing the scene
was stunt actor and Houston native
Joseph Speck both a veteran of the
profession and a qualified parachutist
but during the filming of the ejection
Speck inexplicably failed to pull his
rip cord the parachute never opened and
he plummeted to his death according to a
manager of the California City airport
where the scene was being filmed an
investigation revealed that nothing was
wrong with Spec's shoot suggesting that
it was either a simple error by SPC or
that he somehow lost Consciousness
during The Plunge in the 1930s Jack
Budlong wasn't strictly a sunt performer
he was also a professional Horseman and
actor but for the 1941 movie they died
with their boots on a civil war classic
about General kuster that starred arol
Flynn Olivia to havin and Jee lockart
Bud long was brought in for the film's
sprawling War scenes reportedly Bud long
played both Union and Confederate
soldiers at various points in the
production and it was during one
sequence when he was in the southern
Grays that the horse rider was killed
Bud long who is said to have been a
close personal friend of Flynn had
persuaded the star into getting him a
role as a stunt performing extra during
the film's war scenes not much of a
veteran stunt actor though budl Long's
inexperience may have been what led him
to insist on using a real saber rather
than a prop so when during filming his
horse began bucking due to the simulated
artillery expl floating around them
Budlong was tossed off the animal and
landed right on his very real very sharp
blade Budlong was taken to a Los Angeles
hospital but it was far too late for him
the saber had punctured his abdomen and
exited via his back he wasn't the only
casualty of filming though as the
production of they died with their boots
on led to countless injuries and at
least two more deaths besides Bud law
you know what's there waiting beyond
that
beach immortality take it Brad Pitt's
2004 ancient war movie Troy directed by
by wolf ging Peterson adapted Homer's
zot the epic poem that depicted the
historical Trojan war waged between the
Greeks and the Spartans its filming was
also a massive undertaking and a
throwback to epics of the ' 50s and 60s
which meant it had several large scale
action sequences involving hundreds of
extras it also led to the death of one
of the many stunt actors involved in the
production stuntman George kieri was
admitted to a hospital during filming
with serious trauma to his ankle
according to the Times of Malta while
also suffering chest pains and shortness
of breath he underwent surgery but 2
days later he was head though initially
it wasn't realized that his death had
been related to an onset accident a
later inquiry traced the cause of
kamer's death all back to injuries he'd
sustained while filming an action scene
on Troy an autopsy revealed that kamer's
death was caused by pulmonary thrombo
embolism with the reports stating
pulmonary thrombo embolism is not an
uncommon complication following trauma
fracture of the lower leg surgery to the
lower limb and immobility according to
the investigation the initial injury
occurred when kameri had been jumping
over the side of a gallion but mixed
signals between extras led to him making
an error and jumping from the wrong spot
which he hadn't been prepared for the
1965 film the Flight of the Phoenix
starred James Stewart as a pilot whose
plane crashes in the Sahara desperately
trying to keep himself his crew and his
passengers alive in the remote desert
his only hope is a passenger whose
experience as an aircraft designer has
him convinced they can build a new plane
out of spare parts from the wreck it's a
nail-biting tale of Adventure and
survival but in the making of the movie
A Fame stun pilot who was hired to make
risky aerial maneuvers lost his life an
experienced racing pilot who'd worked in
Hollywood since the 1930s Paul Manz was
well known for helping Amelia aart and
her Navigator Fred Nunan prepare for
their first attempt to circumnavigate
the globe he was practically pilot
royalty in his day but that didn't mean
he was invincible during filming of the
Flight of the Phoenix he was flying low
in a sequence meant to simulate a
takeoff when something went wrong in the
plane crashed killing him ironically it
wasn't even man who was supposed to be
behind the controls that day but his
partner Frank tman at the last minute
though tman injured his knee and mans
filled in with man's death the Flight of
the Phoenix may have been a cursed
production in 2004 Dennis Quaid started
a remake that seriously injured
cameraman Kieran Barry he received a
million dollar settlement though no one
was killed movies about dangerous
professions are inherently going to
involve precarious stunts so when it
came time to film a story about the
construction of a skyscraper there was
extra danger involved experienced stunt
man AJ bakunas was doubling for lead
actor George Kennedy on the Lexington
Kentucky set of Steel when tragedy
struck in the scene he attempted a
daring drop that would feature him
plunging from the top of a high-rise to
simulate the falling death of Kennedy's
character bakunas was a well-known name
in the industry long before he went to
work on the film by all accounts he had
been preparing for the jump for weeks
and decided to increase the length of
his fall to 323 ft instead of the ninth
story leap he'd already completed he
wasn't doing it to make the stunt more
impressive but instead simply hoping to
top a stunt performed on another set by
rival stuntman Dar Robinson who is still
nearly a decade away from his own fatal
stunt theunis completed the jump as
plant but the airbag below ruptured
injuring him critically right in front
of a massive crowd of Spectators who had
assembled to watch the stunt the actor
was still alive and conscious as he was
rushed to the emergency room and treated
but he eventually succumbed to his
injuries aunis was only 27 one thing I'd
like to know are World Records worth the
risk movies involving highflying
aircraft action can be fraught with
danger and typically require the skills
of talented stunt pilots who can pull
off death defying Maneuvers that was the
case with Von R toen and brown a 1971
World War I epic about one of the
greatest flying Aces that history has
ever known a passion project for
director Roger Corman who put up much to
the financing himself the film was shot
in Ireland and told the story of Manfred
Von rck toen also known as the Red Baron
and the pilot Roy Brown who took him
down filming the intense dog fights
though led to a midair Collision that
killed stuntman Charles bodington
following the incident the Irish
government decided to shut down the
Productions aerial scenes that Corman
had scheduled for Weston Airfield not
far from Dublin according to
contemporary accounts boddington's
disastrous crash in the sky wasn't even
the last accident during filming just a
day later pilot Lyn Garrison and actor
Don strad received injuries after an
unscheduled crashed Landing in the liy
river it probably isn't much of a
surprise to learn that there have been
some mishaps on the sets of movies
starring Ronald schwen Egger after all
the overly muscled body builder turned
actor is known for his explosive action
movies from Science Fiction and Fantasy
to military Thrillers in 1988 filming on
his buddy cop action comedy red heat
went a little too far even by Arnold
standards resulting in the death of
stunt actor Benny Dobbins the film which
was dedicated to Dobbins had Arnold in
the role of a Russian military Captain
named Ivan dun he sent to Chicago where
he teams up with a local cop after they
realize they're both looking for the
same criminal filled with guns blazing
shootouts and bare knuckle brawls red
heat is an underrated AR classic but
filming one scene that involved the
Terminator star duking it out hand to
hand with a stunt man who wasn't Dobbins
led to a death in an unexpected way
during the scene Dobbins was serving as
the stunt coordinator helping stage the
scene with his two actors when he
suddenly collapsed suffering a fatal
heart attack Dobbins was airlifted to a
local hospital but didn't survive he was
55 years old and left behind work in
many action Classics like First Blood
Commando and the running man it's time
to start
running